I know cartoons can change the world but
we can certainly try
my crystals were used by activists and
graffiti artists one of my questions was
before the form of art and it was
actually repeated in Lebanon and it was
about Mubarak nope you're kidding in
Egypt and in Yemen
some people use my cartoon in banners
it's really been hard watching what
happened during these five years because
everybody had that hope that finally
change would happen the whole circle
came back and you know just you know
things are still the same most of my
friends are either left the countries or
in jail
how they rested in Egypt and integrated
for a couple of hours actually asking me
if I'm going to draw like I don't know
if I'm going to die note if you don't
want me to go I'm not going to draw
anything it's nice to see that they're
scared of us now it gives us more power
it gives us more confidence in what
we're doing that we're actually doing
something right
you shouldn't say everybody is a savage
because they don't agree with us right
if you just we Charlie and if not then
you're a savage
for me this is an opportunity to reach
out to the other side because basically
we see what what the West thinks of us
but they don't see what we think of them
you